et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois durpaire historien spécialiste
des états unis bonsoir construit vers
merci d'être avec nous merci le
président américain joe biden qui suivra
avec attention dit il ce soir le procès
de derek chauvine
il sera forcément politique françois ce
procès évidemment il a été élu tranche
choix par les noirs américains
une première fois parce que les noirs
américains l'ont sauvé vous vous
souvenez la primaire ça a été très
compliqué et finalement en caroline du
sud c'est la communauté afro américaine
qui l'a choisi deuxième élection en
novembre dernier puis troisième élection
pourrait dire que c'est la communauté
noire qui en georgie a fait basculer le
vote qui a permis à dubaï donne d'avoir
une majorité démocrate au sénat
donc oui c'est évidemment très politique
mais en même temps ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de la salle de tribunal
ça c'est beaucoup moins politique parce
que on ne parlera pas de racisme par
exemple vous avez vu des chefs
d'inculpation il n'ya pas crimes de
haine dans ces chefs d'inculpation
donc on pourra peut-être être déçu parce
que si le débat public à l'extérieur du
tribunal
et ce qui va se passer à l'intérieur du
tribunal sont deux choses complètement
différentes
ça veut dire françois qu'on passe à côté
du débat de fond ou d'une certaine
manière c'était pas vraiment le l'objet
du tribunal le butin de parler de
racisme et on aurait peut-être dû vous
pensez alors je ne pense rien simplement
en analysant l'évolution de la justice
américaine on peut dire que des choses
ont évolué cette justice elle est le
produit d'une société mais elle a évolué
ce qu'on cherche à ne pas voir se
reproduire
vous l'avez dit dans le reportage c'est
les images il ya quelques mois mais
c'est aussi les événements 1992 suite à
l'acquittement de policier blanc vous
savez qu'il y avait tabassé ronde des
kings à los angeles il y avait eu plus
de 50 morts suite à cet acquittement
dans les douze jurés 17 et blanc cette
fois c'est différent dans les douze
jurés
quatre seront des afro américains il n'y
en avait pas en 1992 donc l'idée c'était
pendant ces trois semaines de faire des
entretiens les plus précis possibles
pour écarter des membres
un peu gelé dire que donc dans la
conviction et chef d' avance alors
évidemment si vous êtes policier on peut
se dire vous avez peut-être une
solidarité professionnelle
si vous êtes raciste on va se dire
peut-être que vous allez à tout prix
vouloir sauver ce policier
mais si vous êtes un militant
antiraciste membres des du black light
ce matin va vous n'avez pas non plus
d'être des chances d'être dans ce jury
parce que peut-être votre idée est faite
donc n'a choisi des jurés qui n'ont pas
leurs idées fait et qui pourront juger
sur les faits et ce qui est fondamental
dans le reportage que vous démontrez
c'est ce troisième chef d'inculpation
qui a été décidée meurtre au troisième
degré c'est très important parce que la
preuve sera plus facile de culpabilité
mais en même temps derek chauvine et
bien risque - il restera pas quarante
années de prison mais là seulement 25
l'avocat de derek sauvent in a assuré
que son camp avait agi conformément à sa
formation et a demandé aux jurés de se
concentrer sur les faits loin de toute
autre considération politique le
politique qui revient encore c'est aussi
le procès d'une certaine amérique celle
incarnée par donald trump ou c'est
exagéré de dire cela non parce qu'à
l'intérieur du tribunal où la vie l'idée
c'est de juger un homme et de juger des
faits extrêmement précis mais l'enjeu
c'est que ce verdict soit accepté par la
population américaine vous savez il ya
quelques mois après la mort de georges
de floch quelque chose s'est passé dans
la société américaine
il n'y avait pas les noirs contre les
blancs il y avait pour la première fois
de l'histoire du pays une majorité de
blancs américains qui se disait il y a
un vrai problème dans notre police il ya
un problème de violence et bien un
problème peut-être de racisme c'est une
majorité aujourd'hui de blanc qui le
disent il ya le 3 mars dernier à la
chambre des représentants une loi qui
est passé d'ailleurs valois s'appelle
georges floyd cette loi prévoit
notamment est bien de créer un fichier
de policiers qui auraient été renvoyés
alors le paradoxe c'est quand vous
est un policier aux états unis que vous
êtes renvoyé pour violences dans une
police mettons à los angeles
vous pouvez aller à san francisco et
postuler il ya pour rentrer dans la
police de san francisco ca les députés
n'en veulent plus on va aussi interdire
les étranglements alors attention cette
loi n'est pas encore passer devant le
sénat il faudra que le sénat est bien
valide cette loi et ça c'est pas du tout
fait 1 et le vote au sénat n'est pas
acquis on sait que c'est une amérique
fracturé on sait qu'il ya eu au
lendemain évidemment de cette affaire
giorgio floyd beaucoup de deux
manifestations pendant des semaines des
mois
ce verdict va être suivi de près on
l'imaginait ce qui peut mettre de
l'huile sur le feu et relancer justement
ces émeutes aux états unis bien si vous
voulez même si le procès et judiciaire
et non pas politique
cette idée du troisième chef
d'inculpation je reviens là dessus parce
que ça me paraît fondamental et ça
semble quand même une manoeuvre de la
justice américaine pour dire mon cherche
à sortir d'un dilemme et ce dilemme il
est là en mettant ce chef d'inculpation
qui est plus facile à prouver parce
qu'il n'ya pas l'intentionnalité dans le
meurtre au troisième degré mémé qui
remet mais qui finalement aurait pour
conséquence une peine de prison ou à
lourdes on se dit on va échapper à ces
deux choses la première c'est
l'acquittement qui effectivement
mettrait de l'huile sur le feu et puis
la deuxième c'est peut-être une peine
disproportionnée ou derek iovine père et
finalement des siècles de racisme
américain et non pas le crime qu'il a pu
connaître mais ça c'est évidemment le
procès qui le décidera ce ne sont pas
les commentateurs ce sont les dunes géré
de manière indépendante qui vont le
décider justement dernière petite
question françois vous avait déjà parlé
des jurés mais avec cette extrême
médiatisation comme souvent même en
france à est ce que ces jurés arriveront
à rester parce et impartiaux
ça paraît très compliqué stéphanie
d'abord parce qu'on n'a pas délocalisé
le process aurait pu être une solution
délocaliser ce procès ça n'a pas été le
cas ce procès a lieu bien à minneapolis
et puis la deuxième chose rapidement
c'est que quelque chose a également
changé dans la société américaine comme
dans toutes les sociétés c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez eu 330 millions
d'américains témoin oculaire de ce qui
s'est passé parce que lorsqu'il y à ce
type d'événement bien vous avez autour
est bien plein de gens qui sortent leur
téléphone portable
parce que sans ces téléphones portables
là eh bien il ya fort à parier que
derecho vide n'aurait pas été arrêté
ça c'est quelque chose qui a changé le
regard de l'ensemble de la société via
via nos appareils numériques qui fait
basculer finalement la société
américaine d'en dire quelque chose de
différent où finalement tous les
citoyens ont leur mot à dire sur la
question leur propre idée de la vérité
merci beaucoup françois durpaire
historien spécialiste des états unis
d'avoir été avec nous